Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Et là, j'espère que vous allez bien. J'ai reçu énormément de retours positifs suite au dernier épisode.
Vous avez été nombreux à apprécier notre entretien au sujet des réactionnaires, des guerres culturelles et autres paniques morales.
Aujourd'hui, comme je l'avais annoncé, on part sur un sujet très différent sur lequel je reviens régulièrement dans Septante Minutes Avec.
On va parler d'autisme.
Je vous cache pas que c'est peut-être l'épisode le plus niche que j'ai jamais sorti. Ma discussion avec Marco Di Duca est centrée sur l'arrêt, entre guillemets,
de la prise en charge des patients adultes en demande d'un diagnostic d'autisme au sein du CRAL au CHU de Liège.
Donc voilà, quand je vous dis que c'est niche, c'est vraiment un sujet précis. Si vous êtes concerné de près ou de loin par l'autisme ou que vous suivez ces actualités, je pense que vous allez passer un très bon moment.
On aborde énormément de sujets passionnants liés à la neurodiversité et à comment elle n'est pas prise en charge par nos institutions en Belgique.
Si en revanche, vous ne connaissez rien à l'autisme et à la neurodiversité de près ou de loin, que peut-être vous vivez loin de notre petite Belgique, c'est pas impossible que le sujet soit un peu compliqué.
Je pense franchement que ça reste accessible, mais peut-être que c'est pas une mauvaise idée de suivre un petit cours accéléré sur ces questions.
Pour ça, vous pouvez soit écouter mon passage à la RTBF où j'explique l'autisme en 10 minutes, ou bien vous pouvez aussi écouter l'épisode du podcast avec la formidable Julie Dachez.
C'était il y a déjà trois ans. J'ai mis tous les liens en description.
Je rappelle pour celles et ceux qui ne le savent pas que je suis autiste et donc ça ne vous surprendra pas de constater que je parle nettement plus que d'habitude dans cet épisode puisque tout ça me concerne directement.
Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Marco Di Duca. Marco, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes psychologue, vous vous spécialisez en ce qui concerne l'autisme et le diagnostic de l'autisme en privé chez l'adulte.
Vous travaillez également en collaboration avec le CRAL, le Centre de Ressources Autisme de Liège.
On va avoir l'occasion de parler aujourd'hui, de faire le point sur le paysage en ce qui concerne l'autisme en Belgique, les ressources, les institutions, la fameuse question du diagnostic chez l'adulte.
Avant de se lancer au cœur du sujet, je vais vous poser une question au sujet de vous-même, de votre histoire. Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à vous spécialiser sur le sujet de l'autisme et depuis combien de temps est-ce que vous travaillez là-dessus ?
C'est un peu un hasard ou un concours de circonstances. En fait, mon parcours professionnel,
dès la fin de mes études universitaires, moi, j'ai fait un passage par l'Université Libre de Bruxelles dans un centre de formation et de recherche
consacré essentiellement à la question du handicap.
OK.
Donc j'ai longtemps travaillé dans ce centre, une vingtaine d'années à peu près,
en abordant entre autres comme question toute la question de, à l'époque, on parlait d'intégration, pas encore d'inclusion, mais toute la question de l'inclusion des personnes en situation de handicap.
Et quand le Centre de Ressources Autisme Liège s'est ouvert, ils ont cherché des professionnels qui avaient un parcours soit très directement avec des enfants, des adolescents, des adultes autistes ou des questions annexes.
C'est à ce moment-là qu'ils m'ont demandé de travailler. Au départ aussi parce que j'ai une formation de psychologue systémicien de la famille, donc j'accompagnais beaucoup les familles des autistes enfants ou adolescents et adultes.
Et donc ça fait une dizaine, une quinzaine d'années ?
Une quinzaine d'années que j'ai abordé de manière plus spécifique toute la question de l'autisme et en particulier la question des adultes autistes qu'on qualifie parfois ou souvent sans déficience intellectuelle.
C'est ça. Alors, on va reparler de toutes ces distinctions. Et donc j'ai choisi de vous interviewer, vous, parce que donc ces derniers mois, on a eu quelques actualités liées à l'autisme en Belgique, notamment,
pour refaire un petit peu le point.
Donc je rappelle qu'en Belgique, quand on veut obtenir un diagnostic officiel et reconnu avec des éventuelles reconnaissances de handicap et des éventuels aménagements, il faut passer par des Centres de Ressources Autisme.
Il y en a de nombreux en Flandre, il y en a un, je crois, à Bruxelles et il y en a quelques-uns, une poignée de centres en Wallonie, dont l'écrasante majorité ne traite que les enfants.
Et il y avait donc le CRAL, le Centre de Ressources Autisme de Liège, dont on a parlé, qui continue à ouvrir sa porte aux dossiers des personnes autistes adultes ou en tout cas en recherche d'un tel diagnostic.
Et disons qu'il y a eu des rumeurs, des informations qui ont fuité comme quoi on songeait à fermer la porte aux adultes au sein du CRAL.
Et donc il y a eu quelques interviews, hein, notamment sur RTL, sur RTC Liège, où on voyait passer l'un ou l'autre directeur médical qui—
voilà, Pierre Gillet, directeur médical du CRAL, qui disait que voilà : « Tout ça a tendance à augmenter par des phénomènes qu'on connaît bien, le numérique, l'addiction à une série de choses.
On veut tout, tout de suite et ça aboutit à un certain recul de l'individu qu'on pourrait étiqueter autiste. » Donc voilà, des discours comme ça que personnellement, je trouvais assez aberrants.
Et donc cette inquiétude de dire : « Mais voilà, il y a un dernier centre qui accepte les patients autistes. » La file d'attente, l'année passée, quand on téléphonait, quand on envoyait une demande,
la file d'attente était de 16 ans.
Puis une menace de voir fermer ce centre, en tout cas aux personnes adultes, et avec des discours assez consternants dans les médias pour l'expliquer.
Donc, vous travaillez au sein du CRAL et vous avez un discours peut-être un peu dissident, qui n'est pas la même ligne, disons, que celle de Pierre Gillet ou de Eric Adam qu'on a pu entendre dans les médias.
Alors je vais vous poser simplement la question : est-ce que ce centre pour adultes va fermer ?
Quelle est la situation aujourd'hui ?
La situation, si j'ai un discours politiquement correct, je vous dirais que la situation est en construction et qu'il n'y a pas de fermeture annoncée, mais une réorganisation.
Si j'ai un discours un peu moins policé, peut-être quelques précisions, mais je pense qu'elles sont importantes et je n'élude pas du tout la question.
J'ai envie de préciser deux ou trois choses pour éviter—
Aidez-moi.
Donc d'abord, les centres de référence autisme, il y en a quatre en région wallonne et Bruxelles. Donc y en a deux à Bruxelles, y en a actuellement deux en région wallonne.
Y en a un à Mons, un à Liège et un troisième qui va s'ouvrir à Namur. Tous les centres sont conventionnés à l'origine, autant pour le diagnostic enfant que pour les diagnostics adultes.
Donc ça, c'est important de—
À l'origine, oui, dans la convention avec l'Inami.
Exactement. Et ça, c'est important de le signaler.
C'est une enveloppe fermée.
C'est une enveloppe fermée. Alors, on va rentrer dans les détails financiers, mais c'est une enveloppe fermée et en même temps, enfin, insuffisante, mais confortable.
On peut pas dire non plus que l'enveloppe au départ était insuffisante. Historiquement, si tous les centres étaient susceptibles de diagnostiquer et d'accompagner des adultes,
il se fait que le CRAL est le seul à l'avoir fait de manière aussi systématique.
Certains centres énonçant volontairement leur décision de ne pas accompagner, de ne pas diagnostiquer des adultes et des enfants, pour des tas, j'ai envie de dire, de bonnes raisons.
D'abord parce qu'ils en avaient le droit, ensuite parce qu'ils estimaient que leurs compétences étaient plus celles-là.
Et donc le CRAL a développé cette compétence, j'ai envie de dire cette expertise, et est devenu un peu, au fur et à mesure des années, le seul centre à effectivement réaliser des diagnostics chez les adultes.
Avec notamment pour conséquence une liste d'attente qui a augmenté. Voilà, en termes d'ordre d'idée, il y a à peu près quatre ans, on était à 5 ans de durée de liste d'attente.
Quand j'ai moi-même téléphoné en 2019, c'était effectivement une durée de quatre ans et demi, cinq ans.
Voilà. Et les chiffres ont explosé sur les quatre dernières années et d'un point de vue très théorique, ils sont arrivés à seize ans.
Pourquoi très théorique ? Parce qu'à un moment donné, y avait plus de liste d'attente.
On sort de la réalité, oui.
Voilà, on est hors réalité. Alors, cette question de la liste d'attente, elle a été— il faut pas croire non plus que les gens du CRAL n'ont rien fait.
C'est-à-dire qu'au moment du transfert de compétences de l'Inami vers les régions, y a eu une interpellation des autorités pour dire : « Mais voilà, que faire ?
Est-ce que vous ne pourriez pas libérer plus de moyens ? » Parce que même si l'enveloppe est confortable, elle est limitée.
Plus de moyens qu'on puisse résorber progressivement cette liste d'attente. Ça, c'est un élément de précision. Le deuxième élément de précision important quand même, c'est la notion de diagnostic officiel.
Donc, les Centres de Ressources Autisme ont notamment comme mission de poser des diagnostics, d'assurer une espèce de suivi des patients ou de leur famille, mais aussi d'assurer que ce diagnostic soit qualitativement,
soit d'une qualité importante et de réaliser ou des recherches ou en tout cas d'avoir une formation et de mener des formations, des informations auprès des professionnels.
Donc le diagnostic a un caractère, entre guillemets, je mets bien des guillemets, plus officiel. D'autres peuvent poser des diagnostics.
Après, on peut questionner la notion de critère, la notion de pluridisciplinarité, etc., etc. Moi, à titre personnel, dans le cadre de mes activités libérales, bah je pose des diagnostics.
Après, je sais que pour la toute grande, en tout cas j'espère, pour la toute grande majorité des gens que j'accompagne, ce diagnostic a une valeur.
Mh.
Pour les autorités, bah tout dépend de quelle autorité il s'agit. Je vais prendre un exemple simple. Des étudiants qui demandent des aménagements pour leurs études, donc des étudiants universitaires.
Bah en fonction de l'université, le diagnostic que je vais pouvoir réaliser va être accepté et suffisant ou pas.
Mh. D'une université à l'autre. Par exemple, vous, vous avez une expérience de ce type avec une université en particulier ?
Oui, si l'étudiant est à l'université de Liège, ou à l'université de Bruxelles, mon rapport va suffire. Si l'étudiant est à l'université de Louvain-la-Neuve, les choses seront moins facilement acceptées.
Voilà, pour prendre un exemple.
Oui, oui, c'est clair, c'est pratique. Donc, de mon point de vue, je dirais que
un diagnostic en libéral, c'est généralement la démarche d'une personne qui cherche des réponses au sujet d'elle-même et qui—
voilà, y a des personnes qui sont en questionnement, qui refusent de s'auto-diagnostiquer et qui veulent vraiment avoir une réponse, avoir une confirmation de la part de—
d'une autorité, une autorité médicale, un psychologue, par exemple, spécialisé.
Voilà, certaines personnes.
D'autres chercheront effectivement la reconnaissance des autorités publiques, le fait que ce soit établi, objectif, qu'ils puissent aller avec ça,
auprès de, par exemple, à l'Université catholique de Louvain, un truc très, euh. Qui est quelque chose qui soit reconnu par, voilà, le paysage,
des institutions en Belgique.
Donc c'est des démarches, voilà, un petit peu différentes. Et donc on en revient à la question donc du CRAL.
Je posais la question : est-ce que c'est la fin des diagnostics adultes au Centre de Ressources Autisme de Liège ?
Mais c'est la fin sous cette forme. Voilà, en tout cas, c'est la fin dans—
Il y a en tout cas une transition.
Il y a une transition. C'est la fin du diagnostic dans le cadre de la convention. Et donc l'enjeu, et je rebondis un peu sur peut-être ces propos un peu malheureux de monsieur Gillet.
Les adultes autistes ou qui s'interrogent sur leur autisme éventuel le font généralement, quand je dis généralement, dans la grande majorité des situations, à l'issue d'un parcours qui est un parcours de vie compliqué.
Alors compliqué parfois dans des choses excessivement concrètes. On connaît par exemple notamment les difficultés d'emploi des adultes autistes. Et donc—
Oui. Et on peut même parler de manière générale d'une grande corrélation, d'une grande coïncidence, disons, entre des personnes dépressives, des personnes suicidaires, des personnes qui pratiquent de l'automutilation,
des personnes qui vont recevoir des mauvais diagnostics,
et rentrer en psychiatrisation, être internées.
Oui, oui, oui.
Des parcours difficiles de toutes les sortes.
Oui, oui, oui. Et vous faites bien d'insister là-dessus. Donc des parcours très difficiles. Et donc on n'est pas dans,
une espèce de coquetterie un peu à la mode, qui voudrait que—
qui laisserait penser que les personnes autistes, à un moment donné, s'interrogent sur leur situation parce qu'ils ont vu un feuilleton qui aborde la question.
On n'est pas du tout dans—
Oui, c'est un argument qui revient beaucoup, c'est que c'est un peu une mode quoi.
Voilà.
Et c'est une idée assez ignare, qui n'est pas basée sur grand-chose à mon sens. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que c'est un argument qu'on entend chez les adultes, pas tellement chez les enfants.
Mh.
Au sujet des adultes et pas tellement au sujet des enfants. Et je pense que c'est révélateur du fait que ça dérange, ça interroge le fait de parler de l'autisme chez l'adulte.
Parce que disons que parler des enfants autistes, il y a souvent un discours
qui se rapproche du caritatif, qui se rapproche du on va prendre soin, on va les prendre en charge, ces enfants autistes, on va les aider, on va leur tendre la main.
Alors que quand on parle des personnes autistes adultes, on est plus sur un discours de l'inclusion, de demander à dire : « Ben voilà, parlons d'équité, parlons d'aménagement.
» Et j'ai le sentiment, et vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez, que
la question de l'autisme chez l'adulte dérange un petit peu auprès de certaines institutions et voilà, et produit ce genre de discours comme quoi c'est un effet de mode.
Oui, mais je réfléchissais au mot déranger. L'autisme adulte remet plein de choses en question.
Mh. Voilà, c'est—
Vraiment. Et notamment le statut du professionnel. Moi, généralement, quand je rencontre des adultes, ben ce sont des gens qui sont excessivement bien informés de la question de l'autisme.
C'est des gens qui en font parfois un intérêt restreint, si je peux me permettre.
Ouais.
Et donc ils remettent en question le statut d'un psychiatre, le statut d'un psychologue. Ça, c'est un aspect.
Il dérange parce qu'il, euh...
Est-ce que vous êtes en train de dire que le psychologue est alors un petit peu agacé et dérangé d'être face à quelqu'un qui pense déjà avoir la réponse et que c'est un facteur dans le...
Mais ils peuvent l'être. Je ne vais pas tirer, voilà, à vue sur mes collègues psy et psychiatres, mais ils peuvent être dérangés par, ou remis en question.
L'adulte autiste remet en question certaines natures d'accompagnement. Je vais prendre des exemples bêtes, mais,
la majorité des psys, quand vous rentrez dans leur cabinet, une de leurs premières questions, c'est de vous demander comment vous allez. Euh...
C'est effectivement une question qui n'est pas forcément idéale pour les personnes autistes.
Mais totalement. Totalement.
On peut peut-être expliquer pourquoi. C'est parce qu'il y a une difficulté à poser des mots sur un ressenti, à décrire exactement qu'est-ce qui se passe dans notre tête.
C'est pas forcément facile.
Oui, oui.
Pour certains plus que pour d'autres, il y a des difficultés. Mais effectivement, j'ai souvent entendu des camarades autistes dire : « Je n'aime pas cette question.
Arrête de me la poser. »
Alors, ça m'oblige de rebondir sur un autre aspect, c'est que vous, vous pointiez la différence de regard posé sur l'autisme enfant, l'autisme adulte.
Voilà, les gens que j'accompagne, adultes ou adolescents, certains me disent qu'ils avaient préparé d'avance la réponse qu'ils allaient donner à cette question, y compris quand ils étaient adolescents et qu'ils bénéficiaient d'un suivi et—
Préparer une réponse à la question : comment ça va ?
Exactement.
Ok, ok. Oui, oui, oui.
Voilà.
Oui, c'est— on scripte, on prépare, on anticipe. Oui, c'est tout ça très autiste, oui.
Et donc il y a des parcours, des suivis psychothérapeutiques de plusieurs années qui se sont construits avec des adolescents sur des bases complètement fausses.
Et donc en ça, ça dérange aussi. Ça remet en question. Alors déranger, j'utilise pas le mot.
Les bases complètement fausses de—
C'est-à-dire que vous avez des psys qui accompagnent des adolescents qui sont parfois donc en grand mal-être, sans nécessairement identifier l'origine de ces difficultés—
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
...sans même pouvoir mettre des mots, qui sont parfois poussés dans le dos par leurs parents pour aller voir monsieur ou madame le psy et qui font semblant.
C'est ça. Oui, donc vous êtes en train de dire que
le masking, le fait de porter un masque et de se demander comment est-ce que je dois paraître, comment est-ce que je dois
me couler dans le moule et disparaître parmi les autres, sembler normal, on va compenser, disons, on va masquer, oui, voilà, une différence par intellect.
On va réfléchir à quoi est-ce que je dois ressembler, quelle doit être ma réponse.
Et donc, et vous dites que c'est quelque chose dont les psys n'ont pas forcément conscience et dont ils ne tiennent pas forcément compte,
quand ils sont face à de tels patients.
Tout à fait. Et voilà, moi, personne ne peut nécessairement le remporter.
Oui, c'est compliqué hein.
Oui, c'est compliqué. C'est compliqué. Et là, ça oblige, et pour moi, c'est un vrai enjeu autour du diagnostic, c'est la représentation qu'on va avoir de ce qu'est l'autisme et ce que ça va impliquer dans,
notamment les pratiques des professionnels qui, à un moment donné, croisent des enfants, des adolescents, des adultes avec ce profil connu ou pas connu. Point barre.
Oui. Et si je peux intervenir à ce moment-là, la question de cette rencontre entre, voilà, ces jeunes patients autistes et ces professionnels pose la question de la formation.
Est-ce que, voilà, est-ce que ces professionnels sont au courant qu'il y a le phénomène de masking ?
Est-ce que les professionnels sont au courant que l'autisme n'est pas forcément le cliché qu'ils ont en tête de Rain Man ou de la dernière série qu'ils ont vue sur TF1 ?
Et je pense savoir, et vous pouvez me corriger si je me trompe, qu'aujourd'hui,
un étudiant en faculté de psychologie qui ne s'intéresse pas spécialement à l'autisme, il ne va pas se former, il ne va pas choisir une option, un master en particulier sur ce sujet, eh bien, va faire ses cinq années
sans vraiment avoir eu de formation à proprement parler sur l'autisme.
Et va ensuite, voilà, éventuellement devenir psychologue clinicien, éventuellement rencontrer de tels patients et ne pas être formé, ne pas être armé face à un tel dossier.
C'est juste de dire ça ?
Oui, ça, c'est totalement juste. Deux, c'est important d'insister, dans le prolongement de ça, sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui, malgré,
une pléthore d'études,
d'universités et d'universitaires brillants, malgré une pléthore de témoignages, cette question de l'autisme adulte et notamment ces stratégies de masking sont des questions qui sont toujours
remises en doute.
Mmh.
Et là aussi est l'enjeu du diagnostic et l'enjeu de
de perpétuer des centres comme le CRA Liège, c'est-à-dire des centres qui
ont aussi pour mission de diffuser une information la plus pertinente, la plus récente et d'ouvrir des questionnements autour de la problématique de l'autisme adulte.
Vous dites ça et puis apparaît dans les médias le directeur médical du CHU de Liège et qui va à contresens de ce que vous venez de dire, qui produit des discours qui vont dans le sens des stéréotypes et pas,
voilà, des études avancées sur les questions de masking, sur ce que vous avez dit, sur les patients qui arrivent très informés.
C'est un discours qui n'est pas compatible à ce que vous venez de décrire.
Oui, vous avez raison. Maintenant, voilà, le directeur médical du CHU n'a pas pour responsabilité de maîtriser l'ensemble des questions que le CHU traite.
Après, il est peut-être à un niveau un peu trop élevé pour connaître toute la technicité de la question.
J'ai envie de dire quelque part, chacun son métier.
Mmh.
Mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau--
un des enjeux ayant des dommages réels de l'éviction des adultes de la convention CRA, même s'il y a une espèce de centre qui va se perpétuer au CHU, l'enjeu fondamental, c'est au-delà du diagnostic.
Donc, il y a une question de
qualité du diagnostic, hein. Ça, je ne veux pas préjuger de comment ces choses vont être faites ou par qui, mais il y a une question
sous-jacente qui est essentielle pour moi, qui est vraiment la question de l'information, de la formation, de la diffusion,
des moyens donnés, laissés
à la nécessité pour les professionnels d'un centre d'être formés, d'être informés et de s'interviser.
Moi, j'ose dire assez simplement que, si on me reconnaît quelques compétences dans la question du diagnostic, de l'accompagnement des adultes, je les ai acquises grâce à mes collègues.
C'est à travers les discussions cliniques, c'est à travers-
Les rencontres avec vos pairs. Oui, oui.
Exactement. C'est comme ça qu'on se forme, hein, au-delà de ce qu'on peut lire, de ce que... C'est, c'est-
Donc voilà, il y a parmi les missions du CRA Liège cette formation continue, cette formation des nouveaux psychologues qui, voilà, qui sont en train de se former.
Et ça, ça vous paraît en bonne voie ou au contraire ?
Oh non, c'est pas du tout en bonne voie. C'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas avancé de... 'Fin, quand je dis qu'on n'a pas avancé d'un iota depuis 15 ans, c'est pas tout à fait vrai, hein.
Y a des, euh... Par exemple, y a, à l'initiative de ACTe qui est un centre installé à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles, il y a un certificat interuniversitaire qui a vu le jour, un interuniversitaire autour de l'autisme.
Et c'est génial. ACTe est un service de pointe qui fait de la recherche maintenant, y compris qui s'interroge sur la question des adultes autistes.
Maintenant, ce n'est pas parce que ce centre existe que la formation initiale des psychologues et des psychiatres, des pédopsychiatres est suffisante ou des paramédicaux au sens large et,
certainement que la formation continue est insuffisante aussi.
Or, il y a vraiment des pistes à investir par rapport à ça. Et donc, 'fin, plus que des pistes, des moyens à investir.
C'est en ça que peut-être que la suppression CRA adultes, 'fin, je mets des tas de guillemets autour de ça, peut être-
On peut peut-être expliquer concrètement ce qui va se passer. Donc il y a une scission, une division
du CRA tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui, entre d'une part un CRA pour les enfants et les adolescents et d'autre part un CRA dédié aux adultes.
Le CRA pour les enfants et les adolescents reste subventionné par la convention de l'INAMI. Ce ne sera pas le cas de la partie adulte.
C'est un choix assumé, voilà, de se diriger
en priorité vers les enfants. Le discours qui est présenté, c'est de dire que
il faut diminuer les files d'attente, diminuer les délais en priorité chez les jeunes enfants, puisque c'est une période importante en termes d'apprentissage et qu'il faut prendre ça en
en compte le plus tôt possible.
Et donc, on subventionne la partie enfants et adolescents avec l'enveloppe de l'INAMI. Et financement un peu plus opaque, un peu plus mystérieux au sujet de la partie adulte.
Vous pouvez nous expliquer ?
Je ne... Ben, 'fin, voilà, moi, je n'ai pas d'information claire par rapport au financement de la partie adulte.
Le discours du CHU, c'est de dire : on va mettre en place tous les moyens disponibles pour diminuer l'impact sur le patient.
Ce qui est très bien. Moi, je ne sais pas exactement comment ils vont faire. Et si c'était aussi simple que ça, 'fin, ça aurait pu être fait avant.
L'un n'empêchait pas l'autre. Mais au-delà de ça, il y a l'aspect financier à charge du patient, mais ça ne résout pas l'aspect,
les moyens financiers qui sont nécessaires pour maintenir une qualité au sein de l'équipe et une dynamique qui est vraiment une dynamique pluridisciplinaire.
Et vous, vous êtes déçu, justement, puisque vous parliez de cet échange avec vos pairs, vous êtes déçu de cette scission de...
Ah moi, j'ose dire, parce que je le pense fondamentalement, que c'est une aberration. C'est une aberration à plein de niveaux.
D'abord, je reviens un peu sur ce que vous disiez, priorité aux enfants. Bien entendu que ça fait partie des priorités.
C'est-à-dire-- mais pour un certain profil d'enfant aussi. Je veux dire, quand on parle des prises en charge précoces, on parle d'un certain profil d'enfant qui--
on parle moins de ces enfants adolescents qui sont diagnostiqués beaucoup plus tardivement et donc qui nécessitent aussi un accompagnement.
Mais on sait que dans le parcours de vie de ces enfants, de adolescents avec un profil autistique différent, hein, souvent avec justement plus de masking, etc., etc.,
les difficultés, elles vont se poser à des moments autres et notamment dans, au passage de la vie adulte.
Et qu'il n'est pas rare de voir des,
des adolescents réussir une scolarité sans grande difficulté et puis échouer
soit au moment des études supérieures, soit après les études supérieures, au moment de l'emploi, parce qu'il y a des tas d'autres exigences auxquelles ils ont du mal à faire face.
Ça, c'est un aspect des choses. Le deuxième aspect qui fait que je trouve dommage, voire dommageable, de créer une scission entre enfants et adultes, c'est qu'on n'exploite pas assez
ce que les adultes nous apportent comme informations de leur jeunesse, de leur enfance, de leur adolescence.
Et on ne les exploite pas assez pour soit diagnostiquer des adolescents qui viennent avec une suspicion d'autisme.
Et parfois, on va ne pas confirmer cet autisme pour de mauvaises raisons, entre guillemets. On n'exploite pas assez pour ça.
Et les informations apportées par les adultes sur leur adolescence pourraient éventuellement être des clés pour mieux comprendre ces profils-là.
C'est pas pourraient, c'est vraiment peuvent.
Mh.
Vraiment.
Vous avez un exemple de ça, concret, sans rentrer dans l'intimité des patients, mais quelque chose qui vous a été raconté par un patient adulte et qui vous a permis de...
Mais on parlait du masking tout à l'heure.
Oui.
Concrètement, mais c'est en lien avec le masking-
Bien sûr, bien sûr
...et en même temps, c'est-- je veux dire,
pour ainsi dire, tous les adultes expliquent qu'ils ont, à un moment, eu ce sentiment d'étrangeté, c'est-à-dire ce sentiment d'être un peu différent sans nécessairement identifier le pourquoi.
Mais ce sentiment d'étrangeté, il vient très vite et parfois de très tôt dès l'école primaire. Et il est à l'origine d'un ensemble de stratégies dont le masking.
Mais comme il est à l'origine de parfois des situations plus graves comme du harcèlement ou comme de l'isolement ou même de l'automutilation, etc.
Donc ça, c'est quelque chose qu'on n'exploite pas du tout ou pas suffisamment.
Mmh.
Et bah dans le prolongement, pour faire un-- ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, c'est toute cette question autour du ressenti, autour des émotions, autour de mettre des mots sur son ressenti interne.
Bah, les adultes disent que c'est compliqué, mais ils disent que c'est compliqué depuis, entre guillemets, toujours.
Ça aussi, c'est quelque chose qu'on exploite très très peu et qu'on exploite, enfin de mon point de vue, insuffisamment lorsqu'on pose un diagnostic, y compris chez des enfants et des adolescents.
C'est un domaine qu'on investigue, de mon point de vue, pas suffisamment. Et j'en ai déjà plusieurs fois discuté avec mes collègues du CRA.
Y a vraiment là des éléments qui mériteraient d'être approfondis parce que ça amène par la suite plein de pistes.
Et parfois, c'est une nécessité pour éviter aussi des complications, voire du sur-handicap. On ne mesure pas nécessairement suffisamment que le fait de ne pas,
correctement appréhender ses propres vécus a des conséquences sur, ben notre santé au sens large du terme, y compris physique, puisque
l'émotion sous-jacente, par exemple l'anxiété, elle va s'exprimer par ailleurs et parfois de manière somatique, pour prendre un exemple simple.
Oui. Donc, on fait vraiment le constat d'un échec et d'un manque de moyens, d'un manque de ressources pour bien appréhender ces questions.
J'vais peut-être sortir du contexte du CRA. Et voilà, on parlait de ces jeunes enfants ou jeunes adolescents qui ressentent ce sentiment de différence sans forcément pouvoir poser des mots dessus.
Alors, dans le cas idéal, on présenterait sur leur chemin un ou une psychologue formé, expert en la matière, qui pourrait reconnaître, voir les signes de l'autisme.
Et si c'est pertinent, si ça bénéficie à la personne, présenter cette étiquette-là. Y a d'autres psychologues, d'autres sortes d'accompagnants qui ont d'autres étiquettes à présenter.
J'pense notamment au-- puisqu'on parlait de la mauvaise formation des psychologues aujourd'hui qui n'entendent jamais parler d'autisme quand ils sortent d'universitaires.
On peut trouver de nombreux psychologues qui vont aller s'inspirer des centres Cogito's en France et qui vont rencontrer ces jeunes enfants et leur dire qu'ils sont HP, qu'ils sont hauts potentiels, qu'ils sont des zèbres.
Quel est votre regard sur ces pratiquants-là ?
Ah. Débat large. Moi, voilà, je ne prétends pas avoir une quelconque expertise dans toute cette question du haut potentiel intellectuel.
Maintenant, si on regarde quand même d'un peu plus près la littérature scientifique autour du haut potentiel intellectuel, y a deux grands courants.
Y a un courant qui est, qu'on va qualifier d'essentialiste, qui grosso modo dit : les personnes avec un haut potentiel intellectuel ont des caractéristiques communes et on parle d'hypersensibilité émotionnelle, etc., etc., de-
Et l'autre grand courant, alors ?
Mais justement, voilà. Y a d'un côté ce courant essentialiste qui dit : ben non, les personnes HP ont des profils, des pensées en arborescence, des hypersensibilités émotionnelles, etc.
Et puis, y a un courant qui est un courant peut-être plus rigoureux, hein. Alors, je sais que c'est un qualificatif un peu-
Un peu biaisé.
Voilà. Mais qui dit : mais non, ça non, y a pas de profil type. Maintenant, y a quelque chose qui est entre les deux, qui est pas inintéressant.
J'ai un patient qui me disait : « Mais moi j'ai des gens qui ont été qualifiés d'HP, de zèbre, et le fait d'avoir été qualifiés d'HP, de zèbre, les ont beaucoup aidés. »
Ouais.
Voilà. Et donc-
Mais de même que la psychanalyse a aidé certains patients et sont ravis d'avoir été voir un psychanalyste. On peut malgré tout s'interroger sur la pertinence de certaines méthodes et certains-
À titre d'exemple, y avait, j'avais eu un échange comme ça, indirect avec un centre, justement, un service pour étudiants à besoins spécifiques d'université.
Et puis, il avait été question de se dire : mais tiens, est-ce que présenter un haut potentiel intellectuel signifie qu'on a droit à un service d'étudiants à besoins spécifiques ?
C'est tout le paradoxe. C'est-à-dire, mais alors,
on peut-- moi, je suis un peu bête quand je dis ça, mais j'peux imaginer que les gens qui font des études supérieures sont des gens qui ont un QI,
au moins dans la moyenne, voire au-dessus de la moyenne, qu'on peut y avoir une proportion plus importante de personnes avec un HP.
Et donc, toutes les personnes avec un HP, et donc une certaine partie importante des étudiants universitaires auraient, seraient des étudiants à besoins spécifiques au nom du fait qu'ils ont un HP.
'Fin, là, on rentre dans quelque chose qui est aberrant.
En fait, la grande difficulté que j'ai avec cette notion de HP, c'est que c'est une définition qui est assez variable, comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure.
Et parfois, ça va être employé pour désigner des personnes effectivement avec un QI relativement élevé. Parfois, on va parler de zèbre, on va parler de HP pour parler de quelqu'un qui-
Voilà, à des hypersensibilités émotionnelles, à des troubles de l'attention.
Et finalement, pour moi, c'est un terme vraiment fourre-tout où on va avoir des traits, mais
que j'aurais plutôt tendance à attribuer à des diagnostics qu'on peut trouver par exemple dans le DSM, qui ont été sujets d'études scientifiques plus rigoureuses, comme par exemple le trouble de l'attention, par exemple l'autisme.
Souvent, oui, effectivement, la question d'un quotient intellectuel peut-être plus élevé que la moyenne.
Et on va, voilà, prendre tous ces profils-là et dire : « Mais voilà, tu es HP ». Et avec aussi, dans ces écoles de pensée-là, et je pense en particulier au Centre Cogito en France,
un petit peu une logique, puisqu'elle n'est pas bien informée sur la nature autistique, ou autre, de certains de ses patients et n'est pas en mesure d'apporter des réponses
qui correspondent vraiment à leurs besoins,
va présenter un discours qui se conclut en disant grosso modo : « Mais tu es trop intelligent pour être heureux ».
C'est un peu ça la logique de ces trucs-là. Et donc moi, je suis toujours très mal à l'aise dès que j'entends quelqu'un parler de ces trucs-là, parce que c'est fourre-tout et c'est...
'Fin, comme vous le disiez, y a des patients que ça a aidé. Mais moi, je vois ça comme une absence de bonne réponse, finalement.
Mais encore une fois, plutôt biaisé de ma part.
Oui, mais je vous rejoins. Ça soulève quand même un autre enjeu, si je peux me permettre de revenir à la question de l'autisme, qui est,
le risque de véhiculer la même représentation pour le diagnostic de l'autisme.
C'est de dire : « Mais c'est une espèce de fourre-tout ». Alors que précisément, enfin, moi, je défends la position totalement inverse. C'est un profil.
C'est un spectre.
Une grande variété.
Oui, mais avec des-
Des patterns ?
...des patterns identiques, avec des patterns communs qui vont s'exprimer de manière parfois différente, mais les patterns sont là.
Et les patterns et les liens entre les patterns. Maintenant, il ne faut pas limiter ces patterns
aux représentations un peu toutes faites de : « Bah, y a des difficultés au niveau des relations, au niveau de la communication et puis des intérêts un peu particuliers ».
Les choses sont à nuancer. Il y a des difficultés, il y a des particularités, je préfère ce mot-là, mais elles vont s'exprimer de manières différentes et pas de manière aussi caricaturale qu'on se l'imagine.
Vous parlez, oui, voilà, justement, de la, des caricatures, de la représentation de l'autisme dans l'imaginaire collectif et de la grande diversité qu'il y a en réalité, malgré, oui, effectivement, la présence de patterns.
On peut se reconnaître entre nous, on a un petit radar. En fait, quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à l'autisme et à mon propre autisme, j'ai donc, dans le cadre de ce podcast, c'était il y a quelques années, je me suis rendu au SUSA.
J'ai interrogé donc Éric Willaye et Guillermo Aguirreoa. Et on parlait de la question de la diversité des profils. Donc j'ai entendu, par exemple, là-bas, qu'il est absolument faux de dire qu'il y a autant de patients femmes que d'hommes.
C'est majoritairement des hommes et nous, des femmes, ici, on en voit très peu. J'avais ensuite réalisé un autre épisode avec Hugues Dayez, donc le monsieur cinéma de la RTBF, pour parler de cinéma.
Et on a également parlé de son fils autiste. Et là, il y avait un discours
assez typique de la part des parents, et c'est vers ce sujet-là que j'aimerais vous amener, qui était de prononcer un grand agacement
vis-à-vis des personnes qui s'expriment au sujet de l'autisme dans les médias, des personnes autistes.
Un grand agacement de dire : « Mais on ne veut pas que ce soit ça l'image par défaut. On présume que l'autisme, c'est un truc sympa
chez des gens très autonomes et très intelligents, alors que nous, les parents, on souffre, on rentre chez nous, on a un enfant en crise et,
et on noie notre détresse dans l'alcool et les médicaments », etc.
Il y avait un grand agacement qui, voilà, qui est inhérent vis-à-vis du spectre et de la grande diversité de profils, du fait que l'autisme tel que eux le rencontrent dans leur vie
n'est pas du tout celui qui est forcément représenté quand, par exemple, Guillaume Hachez passe à la RTBF le dimanche matin pour expliquer l'autisme pendant dix minutes.
C'est pas exactement
la même chose. Et il y avait vraiment un agacement presque violent. Et donc il y a une scission importante entre les discours, d'une part du corps médical, des psychologues, qu'ils soient formés ou non.
Et voilà, un certain discours va venir de cette famille-là.
Un autre discours va venir de la part des personnes directement concernées, qui va prôner plus d'inclusion, qui va prôner une, voilà, une reconnaissance de handicap, une diversité de profils
et qui va demander à pouvoir prendre la parole et apparaître dans l'espace médiatique
pour être connu de la population générale.
Et enfin, on a les parents qui n'aiment pas du tout ce dernier discours et qui sont très agacés. J'ai pu discuter avec des personnes sur-- il y a un groupe Facebook
Autisme Belgique et j'ai pu discuter avec une des administrateurs qui m'expliquait qu'elle, l'autodiagnostic, ça la mettait très mal à l'aise et qu'elle avait l'impression qu'il y avait beaucoup d'imposteurs et que...
'Fin, il y avait une prise de position qui était vraiment en décalage avec les discours qui émanent davantage des personnes concernées.
Et voilà. Et effectivement, donc plutôt une envie que quand on parle d'autisme dans l'espace public, ça doit être cohérent avec leur expérience, qui est une expérience peut-être
mais qui est davantage celle de crise, de meltdown, de difficultés, de handicap important.
Et donc voilà, une grande, grande scission entre ces trois grandes familles pour présenter ça comme ça. Comment est-ce que vous voyez ça de votre point de vue et comment est-ce que vous voyez ça évoluer à l'avenir ?
Je pense que le discours des reculés a...
C'était il y a trois ans. Peut-être qu'il a évolué.
Il y a trois ans, ça, c'est dommage parce que j'espère qu'il a évolué depuis. Enfin, il y a trois ans. Enfin, on sait depuis bien plus longtemps qu'on n'est pas dans un ratio,
homme-femme tel qu'on l'expliquait il y a, tel qu'on le présentait il y a dix ans.
Après, le problème, c'est un peu de supposer la souffrance, hein. Moi, je respecte tout à fait les difficultés des parents.
Et comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure, quand j'ai commencé à travailler au CRAL, une part importante de mon travail était d'accompagner les familles.
Et alors je le fais moins maintenant, mais il y a une vraie souffrance et elle est légitime.
Mh. Tout à fait.
Voilà. Donc la question n'est pas de délégitimer cette souffrance, mais la question, c'est quand même aussi de me dire : oui, mais être adulte autiste, ça n'est pas sympa.
Je veux dire, parce qu'on présente un peu parfois les choses de cet ordre-là.
Mais je veux dire comme par exemple moi-même, mon profil, j'ai plus, j'ai des difficultés, mais je reste-- J'ai beaucoup de privilèges et j'ai une vie relativement confortable. Et
malgré tout, voilà, je parle d'autisme dans l'espace public et
et je peux comprendre que effectivement, ces personnes-là, quand elles écoutent mon discours, et j'essaie de toujours préciser que voilà, il y a une grande diversité de profils et que
ça n'est pas forcément toujours comme chez moi,
mais je peux comprendre effectivement un certain agacement.
Oui, mais il y a des discours qui ne sont pas entendus parce qu'ils ne sont pas prononcés. Donc, il y a des adultes qui sont dans des situations qui sont dramatiques.
Il y a des adultes qui parlent et qui évoquent explicitement une demande d'euthanasie. Il y a-
Oui, tout à fait.
Voilà, il y a-- On sait que les chiffres sont affolants en termes de tentatives de suicide.
Il n'y a pas de chiffres en Belgique, mais je pense qu'en France, il y a eu des ressources à ce niveau-là, des enquêtes au sein de personnes autistes qui ont : avez-vous déjà songé au suicide ?
Avez-vous déjà pratiqué l'automutilation ? Et les ratios sont vraiment, vraiment au-delà de la moyenne générale.
Oui.
De ces constats-là. Et, mais en même temps, ces personnes-là ne sont pas forcément les profils qui seront d'humeur à aller parler à la radio, expliquer l'autisme.
Ils ne sont pas en situation de le faire, je dirais.
Ils ne sont pas en situation de le faire. Et même quand ils le font, ils ne le font pas, entre guillemets, bien. On ne peut pas dire que les personnes autistes sont nécessairement les meilleures communicantes.
D'accord.
Sur ce type de propos et de situation.
Je ne vais pas le prendre personnellement.
Quand je veux dire les meilleures communicantes, je prends une question très précise qui est : vous savez qu'en Belgique, la notion de handicap passe par le SPF Handicap.
Et dans le SPF Handicap, il y a une série de critères. On va pas débattre là-dessus, mais il y a un avis qui est donné par un médecin conseil.
Quand je dis que les personnes autistes ne sont pas très bonnes communicantes sur leur situation, c'est qu'elles ne vont pas exprimer leurs difficultés, leurs douleurs
avec le même écho dramatique que d'autres personnes peuvent le faire.
C'est à ce niveau-là aussi que je voulais insister.
Ça rentrerait dans votre définition du masking ?
Oui, ça peut rentrer dans la question du masking. Ça va rentrer aussi dans la manière, cette difficulté de cohérence entre ce que je vis et la manière dont j'exprime ce que je vis.
Et ça, c'est quand même très très très présent dans l'autisme.
Oui, d'accord.
On a entendu aujourd'hui, voilà, cette proposition au niveau du fédéral, enfin, cette décision au niveau du fédéral de remettre au travail les cinq cent mille personnes en situation de maladie longue durée.
Je n'ai aucun chiffre par rapport à ça, mais je serais curieux de savoir combien de personnes présentant de l'autisme font partie de ces cinq cent mille personnes. Il y a des coachs-
Éventuellement, des personnes qui n'ont pas été diagnostiquées, qui ne sont pas au courant de leur situation.
Exactement. Exactement. Enfin, voilà. Donc la question de la souffrance, elle soulève tout ça. Et il s'agit pas, je me répète, de dire il y a une souffrance qui est plus légitime ou moins légitime que l'autre.
Mais précisément, accordons à la souffrance la même légitimité, et ne nourrissons pas trop cette caricature de l'autisme où finalement, c'est plutôt sympa.
Je veux dire, il y a des gens qui s'en sortent vraiment bien. Il y a des gens qui ne sont jamais diagnostiqués et parce qu'être autiste ne signifie pas nécessairement qu'on soit mal.
Dès lors où on trouve des,
des conditions de vie qui conviennent, où on trouve une carrière professionnelle qui convient, où on se crée les liens amicaux ou intimes utiles ou nécessaires ou ce qui nous correspondent, etc., etc.
Donc-- Mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut ne pas entendre ou ne pas laisser l'espace de parole utile, enfin l'espace de parole où vont pouvoir s'exprimer ces parcours, ces personnes et de leur souffrance.
Voilà, je reviens au CRAL. Et là, je pense que ça, c'est un espace qui perd, qui va disparaître.
Est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le CRAL, jusqu'à présent, permettait de donner une plateforme, donner un espace de parole aux personnes concernées ?
Ça en donnait l'illusion, en tout cas. Ça nourrissait l'espoir. Ça nourrissait l'espoir. Moi, je pense vraiment, je pense vraiment que au-delà du symbolisme, c'est vrai qu'à partir du moment où
dans l'espace francophone, il n'y a plus cette référence, qui va servir un peu de repère ?
Je ne dis pas que, voilà.
Alors, je vois sur votre bureau un flyer de l'ASBL Autistes Associés à Liège. Est-ce que cette réponse ne va pas venir alors
de l'associatif et des personnes concernées qui vont mettre en place, voilà, des sites web, des groupes Facebook, des associations et créer un espace, un réseau d'information tel qu'il n'est pas pris en charge par les autorités ?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas une possibilité pour l'avenir, ça ?
Alors, c'est une possibilité. C'est une possibilité. Tu vois, c'est-
C'est aussi un échec.
Bah, le monde associatif tente de faire ça depuis longtemps. Il est-- donc il est important qu'il soit associé à ce questionnement.
Il est important, enfin de mon point de vue en tout cas, que les personnes autistes elles-mêmes prennent la parole, personnes et parents, etc.
Mais il est aussi primordial que les professionnels se mouillent dans cet échange, cette volonté-
D'accord.
De développer des choses différentes.
Cette solution-là ne résoudrait pas la question de l'information, de la formation continue.
Non. Avec... 'Fin, pour moi, l'enjeu va bien au-delà. C'est à la fois de répondre à ces questionnements individuels, j'ai envie de dire, mais au-delà des questionnements individuels.
C'est que les questionnements sont entendus par ailleurs. Je veux dire, avoir un diagnostic, c'est une étape essentielle dans le parcours de ces personnes.
Avoir un diagnostic, entre guillemets, de qualité. Quand je dis de qualité, c'est aussi un diagnostic qui explique. C'est-à-dire que vous parliez tout à l'heure de l'autodiagnostic.
Ouais.
Ce dont les gens ont besoin, c'est de rencontrer quelqu'un qui va mettre des mots sur leur propre fonctionnement et qui va un peu servir aussi de miroir par rapport à ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ont besoin de comprendre comment ils fonctionnent au-delà de la manière dont ils ont pu le comprendre à travers leurs rencontres, à travers leurs livres, leurs lectures, etc.
Donc, vous estimez que l'autodiagnostic n'est pas une réponse suffisante et que-
Je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas une réponse suffisante. Moi, je vous fais état de
mon expérience. Voilà, moi, je prétends pas connaître tout de l'autisme ou connaître tout de la situation des adultes autistes, mais moi, je rencontre des gens ici qui disent : « J'ai besoin qu'on valide mon autodiagnostic.
» « J'ai besoin qu'on mette des mots dessus. Et j'ai besoin que, à la fois qu'on mette des mots, qu'on valide, que je comprenne mieux certaines particularités que j'ai.
Et puis qu'éventuellement, on explique. C'est-à-dire que moi, j'ai aussi besoin qu'on explique à d'autres, qu'on explique à mes proches. »
Forcément, forcément, les gens qui viennent vous voir sont des gens qui cherchent à vous voir. Des gens qui cherchent à avoir votre expertise et votre avis.
Pas forcément tout le monde. Il y a des personnes qui peuvent lire les livres de Julie Dachez, qui peuvent regarder les vidéos d'Alistair, qui peuvent écouter Septante Minutes Avec et qui peuvent se dire : « Ah tiens, effectivement, ça m'intéresse.
» Et puis faire des rencontres dans le monde associatif, par exemple, et s'informer petit à petit, de plus en plus et comprendre des choses au sujet d'elles-mêmes.
Et puis, après quelque temps, après avoir longtemps réfléchi sur la question, vous disiez, vos patients souvent arrivent bien informés sur la question.
Eh bien voilà, la personne peut éventuellement finir par être à l'aise et dire : « Bah oui, je crois que je suis autiste », voilà.
Mh.
Vous avez l'air de vraiment insister sur la nécessité ou sur l'importance de-- non ?
Non, non, non, non. Non, non, mais vous avez raison de souligner ça. Moi, j'ai un biais quoi. Voilà, les gens que je rencontre sont des gens qui viennent me voir.
Donc par définition, c'est des gens qui me demandent mon avis. Et donc il y a des tas de gens que je ne rencontre pas et qui n'ont pas besoin de me rencontrer.
Et c'est très bien comme ça.
Ouais. Mais c'est souvent remis en question, malheureusement. Beaucoup de gens qui vont dire : « Bah non, tu t'es diagnostiqué tout seul, ça ne vaut rien.
Moi, je vois bien que tu n'es pas autiste. »
Oui, mais enfin, le fait que ce soit diagnostiqué par un professionnel, et notamment moi, ça peut être remis en question aussi.
Oui, mais c'est déjà un argument d'autorité quoi. C'est déjà...
Oui.
Oui, voilà.
Oui, oui. Mais donc ça aussi, ça renvoie alors indirectement à ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure. C'est comment nourrir aussi
la connaissance de tout un chacun, de ce qu'est l'autisme, de cette diversité, de comment ça peut s'exprimer avec ou sans difficulté, et puis on peut même rêver plus loin, de comment
mieux user, utiliser les ressources particulières du fonctionnement des adultes autistes et donc leur atypisme, notamment.
Alors, je vais juste revenir à la question qu'on avait évoquée tout à l'heure, qui était donc les,
les voix qui s'opposent entre, d'une part, les professionnels de santé, d'autre part, les parents d'autistes et, d'autre part, les personnes directement concernées, les personnes autistes.
J'ai le sentiment que cette opposition, ces oppositions sont détrimentales, que c'est un conflit qui n'amène pas à faire avancer les choses.
Et moi, j'ai vraiment le sentiment que c'est un problème de voir ces C'est des positions qui reviennent systématiquement des parents qui disent que non, ça ne compte pas vraiment l'autodiagnostic.
Et oh, vous dites que vous êtes autiste, mais pas vraiment. Alors, je vais reposer la question. Comment est-ce que vous voyez évoluer ça ?
Est-ce que c'est un problème inévitable ou est-ce que ça pourra être amené à évoluer ?
C'est un problème inévitable dans le sens où c'est un problème qui
qui existe depuis toujours, dans le champ du handicap au sens large du terme,
et qui dépasse la question de l'autisme, qui renvoie à la question de la sévérité, de la déficience et son impact sur la situation de handicap et qui renvoie à la question alors de quel moyen je libère pour qui.
C'est une question qui, quand je dis qui se pose dans le champ du handicap depuis toujours, on pourrait même dire de la santé, mais dans le champ du handicap en particulier.
Je dis pas que l'autisme est synonyme de handicap, hein, j'ai pas dit ça,
mais dans le champ du handicap, c'est comme ça que se pose la question de, à un moment donné, mais à qui on donne les moyens à partir du moment où les ressources sont limitées, qui on privilégie ?
Et selon quels critères ? Sans pouvoir non plus énoncer de manière explicite, parfois, des enjeux-
Oui, donc il y a des discours qui ont vraiment envie d'être très conservateurs en matière de qu'est-ce qu'un handicap ? Qu'est-ce qui doit être reconnu comme tel ?
Et voilà, imaginer vraiment une personne
en chaise roulante, une personne qui a vraiment une grande difficulté et on-- va y avoir, on va offrir alors à ce moment-là un discours de type charité où on va être,
gentiment, on va être bon prince, on va être gentil, on va l'aider, cette personne.
Et puis il y a des discours qui ont envie d'être beaucoup plus, voilà, dans l'idée que tout le monde peut avoir des handicaps à plus ou moins grand niveau. Et-
C'est intéressant, hein, ce que vous soulignez en termes de charité, etc. Et là, si vous revenez à l'histoire de la notion de handicap, ça donne des éclairages.
Je vous disais, moi, quand j'ai commencé à travailler, je n'ai pas nécessairement travaillé dans le champ, dans le domaine de l'autisme en particulier.
C'était-- il y avait toute cette question beaucoup plus large de la notion de handicap, la notion de déficience.
Et puis, associé à ça, la notion de place de la personne en situation de handicap, d'intégration, d'inclusion, toutes ces questions sous-jacentes.
Très honnêtement, j'ai pas envie de faire vieux combattant, mais c'est vrai que je suis dans le secteur depuis un certain temps. Je--
les mots ont changé, mais la situation pas fondamentalement.
On reste avec des services qui vont ségréger les choses qui sont utiles, mais avec parfois des aides qui devraient être plus inclusives, qui ne sont pas libérées, avec
des discours qui
qui ont la vie dure.
C'est, qu'est-ce qui est considéré comme du handicap ou pas du handicap ? Avec, même d'un point de vue légal, un accès à des allocations de remplacement de revenus qui dépendent de critères qui sont quand même
parfois presque d'une autre guerre.
Donc, il y a cet aspect-là. Et puis, il y a l'aspect vraiment fondamental, mais qui n'évolue pas nécessairement, c'est la notion de diversité, d'inclusion.
L'autisme renvoie à cette question de la neurodiversité. Mais fondamentalement, tout le monde va dire qu'on est ouvert à la différence. Tout le monde.
Ouais.
C'est un discours
commun. Personne ne va dire, sauf si il a des choix politiques très clairement exprimés, ne va dire qu'il est contre l'idée de travailler avec un adulte autiste et, parce que
C'est tellement, ça va être tellement riche, ce qu'il peut amener.
Mais dans les faits, c'est pas, c'est pas ça l'enjeu. Dans les faits, il est prêt à travailler, mais il va pas comprendre que son collègue ne vienne pas boire un pot avec lui ou...
Donc, les questions d'inclusion sont des questions qui—
Qui datent pas d'hier.
Non, et n'ont pas nécessairement pleinement évolué.
Mh. Ouais, donc, y compris pour l'avenir, vous êtes pas forcément hyper optimiste ? D'après ce que je comprends.
C'est, c'est, oui et non. Oui et non. J'ai le sentiment que l'inclusion et que la neurodiversité est un passage obligé à partir du moment où on reconnaît que nos ressources sont limitées.
Mh. Pour continuer la réflexion que je présentais il y a un instant, moi, j'ai peut-être un avis différent du vôtre quand vous disiez que vous estimez que l'autisme n'équivaut pas à, n'implique pas un handicap.
Moi, personnellement, j'estime qu'une personne autiste qui évolue dans une société
alliste ou non autiste ou neurotypique, ou on appelle ça comme on veut, c'est par définition, mathématiquement, c'est une situation de handicap qui va impliquer toute une série de répercussions.
Et je pense que c'est, voilà, pour terminer la réflexion que j'avais commencé tout à l'heure,
c'est là la grande différence entre les personnes qui pensent que non, le handicap, c'est quelque chose de très visible, c'est très, c'est incontournable, c'est une chaise roulante.
Et alors que le handicap, la différence invisible, hein, comme pour citer le titre de la bande dessinée de Julie Dachez, c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus...
Tout le monde n'est pas prêt, ne souhaite pas considérer comme un handicap. Mais pour moi, le shift, il est là entre ces deux façons de considérer la chose.
On parlait de la question de fermeture du CRAAL aux adultes ou voilà, en tout cas la scission, voilà. Et il y a eu une question au sein du Parlement, la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles à ce sujet pour la ministre Villain.
Donc y a une considération grandissante pour ces enjeux. Donc bon, c'est déjà mieux qu'avant, je pense.
Oui, y a une question grandissante. Après, il faut voir—
D'où on part.
...comment on la traite et qu'est-ce qu'on met là-derrière. C'est-à-dire que—
Oui, en effet.
...vous insistez sur la notion de handicap. Je, la notion de handicap est une notion relative. Et elle est—
Bien sûr.
...une notion qui—
C'est une construction sociale.
Exactement. Exactement. Et d'un point de vue individuel, elle est vraiment spécifique à la personne et donc à son environnement direct.
Mmm-hmm. Oui, c'est la fameuse phrase que j'aime beaucoup et qu'on entend dans certains documentaires sur l'autisme, c'est : « Moi, je suis dans ma chambre, je me sens pas handicapé ».
J'aime beaucoup cette phrase.
Oui. Oui.
Parce que j'aime beaucoup ma chambre.
Mais vous avez raison. Vous avez raison. Donc, en cela, beaucoup de personnes autistes sont et se vivent comme handicapées dans un contexte qui n'est pas, qui ne tient pas compte de leur différence, d'autant plus qu'elle est invisible.
Ce qui est important aussi derrière la notion de différence invisible, c'est que, pour reprendre des mots un peu bateaux, mais les neurotypiques—
Je sais que vous n'aimez pas ce mot.
Non, j'aime pas beaucoup ce mot, mais les neurotypiques n'ont pas accès à la nature de la différence.
Et ça, c'est vraiment, vraiment essentiel. Et donc à l'ampleur ou répercussion que cette différence peut avoir sur la personne, et notamment en termes de souffrance, de handicap, etc.
Ça, c'est vraiment important. Il faut insister là-dessus. Mais
la notion même de handicap en termes d'environnement est une notion qui est aussi piégeuse parce qu'elle sous-entend qu'il suffit d'adapter l'environnement pour que le handicap disparaisse.
Alors, il faut alors s'entendre sur ce que c'est l'environnement. L'environnement, ça n'est pas que l'environnement physique, parce que là, c'est une autre manière de faire ressortir la chaise.
La chaise, on la voit, l'environnement physique, on le voit. Ce qui va générer du handicap chez la personne autiste, c'est aussi l'environnement non physique.
C'est la manière dont les gens l'accueillent, c'est la manière dont elle peut interagir. C'est dans les aspects physiques, c'est aussi les aspects temporels, etc., etc.
C'est tout ça qui peut être à l'origine de difficultés de handicap. Ce que je disais, simplement quand je disais : « Ça ne signifie pas nécessairement une situation de handicap
», c'est qu'il y a des gens qui réalisent leur vie sans nécessairement se poser la question de l'autisme
parce que, parfois par bonheur, ils ont trouvé un mode de fonctionnement qui fait qu'ils n'ont jamais vécu de difficultés ou en tout cas des—
Ça me paraît très théorique.
C'est pas si théorique que ça. Ça n'est pas si théorique que ça. Et ça renvoie à la question de aujourd'hui, est-ce qu'il y a plus ou moins de personnes qui présentent de l'autisme ou est-ce qu'il y a plus de personnes qui
vivent des difficultés liées à ça ?
Socialement, on est peut-être, c'est une question, moi, j'ai pas de réponse définitive sur la question, mais on est peut-être socialement dans une société qui est plus exigeante
pour les personnes qui présentent de l'autisme, pour les personnes autistes.
Que les règles sociales sont différentes, que les carrières professionnelles sont différentes, que les compétences attendues sont qualitativement différentes, etc., etc.
Et que simplement, l'environnement est beaucoup plus sollicitant, ne fût-ce que sensoriellement. Et que ça, c'est un ensemble de facteurs qui génèrent du handicap chez les adultes autistes.
Oui. Oui, mais donc c'est finalement— vous faites la distinction entre le handicap, donc construction sociale, personne autiste qui vit dans un contexte non autiste.
Voilà, moi, j'aime bien le mot alliste. Et d'une part ça, et d'autre part, une personne qui, elle aussi, est autiste dans un contexte alliste, mais n'a pas ressenti le handicap qui est face à elle.
C'est comme ça que je présenterais les choses.
N'a pas ressenti ou a eu l'opportunité de ne pas le ressentir.
S'il ne l'a pas ressenti, est-ce qu'il existe ? Je suis plutôt de l'avis que oui, mais...
Oui, je pense qu'il existe, même s'il n'est pas ressenti.
Voilà. Le débat est clos. On approche vers la, tout doucement, la fin de notre entretien. Vous opérez donc à ce stade, toujours au sein de cette division adulte du CRAAL, même si vous ne voyez pas trop.
Tout ça est encore très récent, mais vous ne voyez pas trop comment ça va fonctionner à l'avenir. Et à côté de ça, vous proposez des diagnostics en libéral.
Et donc là, les délais sont plus courts. J'ai gravé, si on voit un rendez-vous chez vous pour un premier rendez-vous pour diagnostic, il faut attendre à peu près cinq mois.
Les premiers rendez-vous sont en octobre. Est-ce que— parce que concrètement, c'est le discours qui est présenté de la part du CHU Liège, c'est de dire que
bah, c'est le libéral, c'est le privé qui va être à la hauteur des enjeux et qui va répondre aux besoins de la population adulte pour les diagnostics.
Ça présente déjà un premier problème qui est le fait que c'est plus cher pour les patients, c'est moins remboursé qu'une série de rendez-vous, une série de consultations au sein du CHU Liège.
Est-ce que, voilà, est-ce que le paysage belge est à la hauteur des enjeux si on dit que la solution va venir du privé ?
Non, mais— et pour, pour—
Pour la raison que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure, c'est-à-dire la formation.
Exactement. Mais au-delà de la formation, pour la question aussi de— si on prend ma situation personnelle.
Moi, jusqu'à présent, je pratiquais en libéral et au sein du CRAAL. Et j'ose dire que le libéral a profité des opportunités que m'offrait le fait de travailler dans une équipe—
Mh.
Et dans les échanges, avec les échanges que ça permettait. Donc—
On sent que vous le regrettez, hein.
Ça, je le regrette. Donc ça veut dire que, dans l'avenir, si je ne travaille plus qu'en libéral, ma responsabilité est de continuer à me nourrir à travers des rencontres. Donc
si le libéral répond ou peut répondre ou doit répondre, il s'agit de
voir comment constituer, je ne sais pas moi, des pôles d'excellence, des discussions, des échanges, comment permettre aux gens qui travaillent en libéral de
bénéficier d'intervisions, de discuter de situations plus compliquées ou qu'ils jugent plus compliquées, etc.
Donc ça, c'est un enjeu important par rapport au diagnostic. Vous disiez tout à l'heure que
l'associatif, les adultes autistes imaginaient éventuellement
identifier les bons et les mauvais psys, en tout cas les gens qui— je pense que là aussi, y a vraiment un travail peut-être de co-construction à réaliser en termes de : mais quels dispositifs
vont garantir la qualité des avis des professionnels ?
Je— voilà. Mais alors, quelle énergie il va falloir dépenser pour ça ? Et qui va soutenir cette énergie ?
Et là, ça renvoie aussi aux politiques. Vous souligniez tout à l'heure la question parlementaire.
Bon, voilà, cette question parlementaire, elle répond sans répondre, mais elle ne met pas en avant, en tout cas de mon point de vue, suffisamment en avant la situation des adultes autistes.
Vous souligniez tout à l'heure cette tension entre adultes autistes, entre certains professionnels et puis l'avis des parents d'enfants ou d'adultes autistes, mais avec des profils parfois différents.
Vous souligniez aussi cette tension. Donc on n'évitera pas cette tension, mais la question, ça va être de se dire comment on les dépasse.
Et ça, moi, j'ai pas de réponse.
Ouais, c'est compliqué, hein.
Oui, c'est compliqué. Mais il faut pas les dépasser en imaginant que ça n'existe pas.
Mh.
Je— voilà, c'est—
Il faut l'adresser, il faut adresser le problème.
Exactement.
Et pas juste l'ignorer.
Et il faut l'amener en débat, au débat. Et donc—
Ouais.
Ça, c'est intéressant parce que vous— c'est aussi de votre responsabilité en tant que journaliste, de remettre ces questions au centre d'une série de débats.
C'est— mais alors, ça pourrait être le cas pour tout citoyen. Vous savez qu'à la fermeture du CRAAL, y a annoncé, y a eu cette pétition.
Alors, c'est beau ce que ça vaut, mais que 2 000 personnes signent une pétition, je me dis : c'est pas banal, quand même. Euh—
Oui, une couverture dans la presse. Mais oui, effectivement, comme vous le disiez, c'est pas banal. Y a une préoccupation de ces enjeux.
Puis voilà, on— le problème est acté quoi, le problème est constaté. Les réponses, pas tellement.
Les réponses, pas tellement ou pas encore. Maintenant, comme on parlait d'opportunités, le CRAAL adulte existant sous cette forme, en tout cas sous la forme actuelle, qui va bientôt mourir, à la fois, ça pointait
les difficultés, hein, notamment cette liste d'attente importante.
Et en même temps, ça les masquait puisqu'il y avait une espèce de réponse à cette liste d'attente, en tout cas la situation des autistes adultes.
Donc en ça, on peut dire que la fermeture du CRAAL met la lumière sur cette difficulté, mais vous savez comme moi que parfois, les difficultés, même si, voilà, on met le spot sur les poussières sur le sol.
Et puis, si on met les poussières en dessous du tapis, on ne voit plus les poussières. Donc, moi, je sais que les adultes autistes sont fédérés, je sais qu'ils sont capables de se mobiliser, etc.
Mais vous savez comme moi que cette question, elle est pas neuve, contrairement à ce que certains disent. La question de l'autisme adulte—
Mh.
Est une question qui n'est pas neuve.
Disons que j'ai le sentiment que, comme vous le disiez, en 2019, on téléphonait au CRAAL, on avait une liste d'attente d'à peu près cinq ans.
Puis en 2021, 2022, c'était 16 ans. Donc il y a eu un crescendo, la courbe a monté en flèche. Moi, j'ai le sentiment que c'est lié.
Je le présume, hein, mais j'en sais rien vraiment, que c'est lié donc aux nouveaux médias, aux youtubeurs, aux podcasteurs qui en parlent.
Moi, le jour où on s'est rencontrés, donc c'était le 3 avril, à l'occasion de la journée Chaussette bleue organisée par Autisme en actions.
Euh, ben, voilà, la même journée, il y a une personne qui est venue me voir et qui m'expliquait que c'était en écoutant mes podcasts qu'il s'était posé la question sur l'autisme et qu'il s'était interrogé.
Et puis voilà. Et puis aujourd'hui, il s'identifie comme autiste. Je sais pas, je connais pas le reste de son parcours, mais donc je pense que ce qui est nouveau,
c'est la prise de conscience collective et la circulation de l'information vis-à-vis de ces questions que permettent ces nouveaux médias.
Et voilà, je pense que c'est ça qui est nouveau.
En partie, oui, vous avez raison. Moi, je mesure mal, je pense qu'il y a des études, hein. Chamac mettait ça en évidence, le nom de l'autisme à travers les médias, etc.
Mais Julie Dachez, les témoignages de Julie Dachez, la différence invisible, c'est pas neuf.
Ça, elle l'a sorti sur quoi ? Il y a quatre ans ?
Je pensais un peu, oui. Enfin moi, j'avais en tête un peu plus, mais vous parliez de Joseph Schovanec, ses premiers ouvrages, c'est quoi ?
C'est euh deux mille cinq, deux mille six quand même. Voilà. Maintenant—
Mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit les discours dont on parle, ce qu'on trouve dans les livres de Joseph Schovanec, mais...
Oui, oui. Oui, voilà. Oui, vous avez raison. En même temps, là, vous donnez un peu d'eau aux gens qui pensent que c'est un peu à la mode.
Bah non, mais c'est pas— justement, je contredis cette question-là en disant : il y a une information qui devient disponible—
Oui.
...pour permettre aux gens d'être confrontés à des questions au sujet d'elles-mêmes, au sujet d'elles-mêmes.
Maintenant, oui, la question de l'information est une question qui, la disponibilité de l'information est bien plus importante.
Vous, et les témoignages sont bien plus officiels. Alors, j'ai oublié le nom de cette journaliste, mais qui, justement, le deux avril, journée de l'autisme,
présentait son livre sur Arte, vous la connaissez peut-être, qui témoignait de son autisme, livre témoignage, voilà, très, très bien écrit,
et de son parcours et de ses particularités de fonctionnement présentes depuis l'enfance et d'un diagnostic à plus de cinquante ans.
Donc euh—
Sylvie Sandeau ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Évidemment, ce type de témoignage, ça fait écho chez plein de gens et donc, et en particulier chez les gens qui ont un parcours compliqué et qui
s'interrogent depuis longtemps de pourquoi c'est si compliqué et parfois ont posé la question à des tas de psy différents et n'ont jamais obtenu
de réponse satisfaisante à leurs yeux.
Un dernier sujet que vous voulez aborder avant de quitter ou est-ce qu'on a fait le tour ?
On n'aura jamais fait le tour. On n'aura jamais, jamais fait le tour. Voilà, simplement une observation et toute la question de la neuroatypie est une question qui est
pas suffisamment aujourd'hui réfléchie en termes d'éthique.
C'est-à-dire, qu'est-ce que ça signifie, la diversité dans une société, que ce soit une école, que ce soit une entreprise, que ce soit une famille, enfin peu importe, ou un groupe d'amis ?
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie et quel est son apport ? Et comment on donne une place pour que cette diversité s'exprime ?
Pour moi, c'est un vrai enjeu, ça.
Il y a eu
ces dix, quinze dernières années,
une prise de conscience collective vis-à-vis, par exemple, des enjeux en termes
de sexisme, de racisme, des enjeux en termes d'homophobie, de, voilà, de diversité, par exemple en termes d'orientation sexuelle, d'identité de genre, des choses qui s'installent de plus en plus dans le discours public.
Et en ce qui concerne la neurodiversité, bah, on n'a pas encore fait notre révolution. Est-ce que vous me rejoignez ?
Oui. Je vous rejoins pleinement, oui.
Marco Di Duca, merci beaucoup pour ces un peu plus de septante minutes passées avec moi. Et je vous dis à très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Je remercie encore une fois Marco Di Duca pour ces septante minutes qu'il a passées avec moi. Sujet passionnant, sujet d'actualité assez brûlant qui impacte de nombreuses personnes.
Je rappelle que le neuf juin prochain, il y aura une manifestation silencieuse, une manifestation autiste friendly devant le CHU de Liège, justement pour répondre à cette décision que la communauté autiste n'approuve évidemment pas.
De mon côté, énormément de choses qui se préparent pour la rentrée prochaine de Septante Minutes Avec, avec des invités qui pèsent et des changements importants.
Vous allez voir, je vous réserve quelques surprises. Et en ce qui concerne les semaines prochaines, on part normalement sur les TCA et l'antisémitisme. À bientôt.